hello everybody and welcome to my
tutorial on the if statement as well as
assignment operators i've decided to
just combine the two since they're used
very often together anyway
in programming can be
useful very quickly to begin adding some
degrees of logic to your program and one
of the most basic forms of logic that
you can use is just the if statement so
the if statement is used to check to see
if something is the case if it is the
case do something otherwise continue
along and you know don't do anything
under the if statement
so uh one of the most common things that
you're going to use with your if
statement is going to be some sort of
assignment operator so these things are
like greater than less than greater than
or equal to
less than or equal to or just straight
up equal to so let's go ahead and cover
a few of those so to start let's say x
equals five and we'll say y equals
eight
and so a basic if statement would go
something like this like if
x is greater than y
colon enter and it'll just go down here
for you print well if that's the case x
is greater than y
so we can save and run that and we would
see here if x was greater than y it
would have done something but that's not
the case so it did nothing
but if we change this if x is less than
y
and we run it this time
we got x is greater than y but
that wasn't the truth there we go
so anyways it runs the code
um so the next thing that we can do
though is we can add another variable so
i'm just going to delete this and we're
going to add a z and we're going to say
z equals 5.
and now what we can do though is we
could say if
z is less than y which is greater than x
what do we want to do well we can print
y is greater than z and greater than x
save that run it
and sure enough that is the case because
z and x are equal to five and y is equal
to eight but you're able to do uh this
kind of stuff
and what if we did
a equals
3
and then we did something like this
a
save and run that
and yet again we get y is greater than z
greater than x we didn't say anything
about a but you can see that it was
indeed the case here so as you can see
this could get really hairy really quick
and all we're using is these greater
than or less than signs but it turns out
that you can also use there's a couple
other things that we can do
so let's go ahead and cover some of
those so at the same time we could say
um
if z is less than or equal to x
what you know do something so we'll say
print
um
z is less than or equal
to x we save and run that and sure
enough
that is the case
uh because z is actually uh equal to x
they're both five so we know that's the
case and so we can see here that the
less than or equal to sign did its part
there's another thing that we could do
though
uh let me do this z is equal to x and
you can say if z is equal to x but you
can't do this you can't say if z equals
x because it's almost asking like is
that the variable definition or what not
so what you have to do is a double equal
sign and that means if it equals x so
there are some languages where you would
you could say like if something equals
something and then like the double
equals means like is it fully equal so
like if one and then
string one
um those would equal each other but then
they wouldn't you know double equal each
other but in this sense in python uh the
way that you would do it is if z equals
using double equal signs then we would
say z is equal to x save and run it sure
enough that is the case
the other thing that you can say is does
not equal and the way that you do that
is with an exclamation mark equals sun
so if z does not equal
x then we would run this but it does
equal x so it will run but if z does not
equal let's say y
we can save and run that and sure enough
it runs because it is indeed not equal
so those are the basics to the if
statement um as you can see it's very
simple statement but then you can start
adding other things to it and the next
video we're going to add to it is the
else so
stay tuned for the else statement very
exciting uh
change to the if statement so
uh stay tuned for that hopefully you
guys enjoyed hopefully you learned
something new as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support the
subscriptions and until next time